who are we  we are no one our mission is to monitor  extraterrestrial activity on earth Rocco  you know you're not supposed to be north  of canal street who is knuckle let's  relax pawn you're looking for me not too  crazy right two grown men talking to the  wall wall talking back it's a mess but  hey don't worry about it isn't every  port access denied do things out there  you don't need to know that's not the  lie you told me when you recruited me  promise you the secret to the universe  nothing more well what are the secrets  are there  okay okay i'm looking for k have you  seen him sort of a surly older gentleman  he smiles like this k has been dead for  over 40 years  here take this now all you have to do  jump you want me to jump I'm Joe  ok how do you know my name